- Good afternoon, and welcome.
Good afternoon, welcome to you,
and thanks for coming to this lecture,
presented by the Franke Program
in Science and the Humanities.
Some of you are familiar with the program,
and others of you are visiting Yale,
perhaps for the first
time in a long while.
Welcome to Yale.
A hearty and warm welcome to
the Whitney Humanities Center
on this glorious day,
which much of New England is embedded
in a blizzard right now,
but we seem to have dodged
the bullet, as it were.
The Franke Program in
Science and the Humanities
brings together diverse
audiences to explore topics
at the interface between
science, technology,
and the broader university,
the broader areas of knowledges
focusing on the humanities,
so we're excited to have you here today.
I want to, as long as we
have such a robust audience,
I'm gonna advertise our events
coming up in the spring,
lots more of excitement.
In particular, we'll be cohosting,
with the Whitney Humanities Center,
the Shulman Lecture Series,
organized around a course
called Other Minds,
about cognitive science of
humans and animals comparatively.
They're sponsoring a series of lectures,
one this week, on February 15th,
by Alexandra Horowitz from Barnard College
on what is it like to be a dog?
On dog cognition.
February 22nd, Peter
Godfrey-Smith will be speaking
on Paths to the Evolution
of Consciousness.
On April 5th,
Mark Moffett of the
Smithsonian, an ant biologist,
will be speaking on
Social Identity in Ant
and Human Societies,
and on April 26, Anne Harrington
from Harvard psychology
will be speaking of Mindful Minds,
America's Love Affair with Meditation.
The other events cosponsored or sponsored
by the Franke Program
coming up in the spring,
on February 24th, we will cosponsor,
with the History of Science
and Medicine program,
a talk by Dr. Sam Roberts,
director of the Columbia University
Institute for Research in
African American Studies
and associate professor of history
and sociomedical sciences.
He'll be speaking in a conference
on Critical Histories
and Activist Futures:
Science, Medicine, and Racial Violence
at the Yale Medical School.
That's at 5:00 p.m.
We're also, on Friday, March 3rd,
we'll be cosponsoring a conference
with the American Studies program and the
Center for Race, Indigeneity,
and Transnational Migration
here at Yale,
a conference on Mapping
for Social Justice,
Approaches with New Media
and Digital Humanities,
with speakers from eight
different universities
visiting for that whole-day program.
On April 10th, we have Andrea Wulf,
who will be speaking on
"The Invention of Nature,"
her award-winning biography
of Alexander Von Humboldt,
a spectacular book and,
I'm sure, an exciting talk.
On Monday, April 17th,
we have Dr. Hasok Chang,
historian and philosopher of science
from Cambridge University,
speaking on Is There Room
for Pluralism in Science?
That will be here in the Whitney
at 4:00 p.m. on the 17th,
and then, on April 22nd,
we cosponsor with the Yale
Environmental History program,
a conference on New Perspectives
in Environmental History.
That'll be in Luce Hall
all day on April 22nd,
so before we get started,
I wanna thank, of course, Ty Kamp,
assistant director here
in the Franke Program,
and also, the Whitney
Humanities Center staff,
always supporting our
activities marvelously,
so today, it's my pleasure to introduce
Dr. Robin Wall Kimmerer,
who is a moss biologist,
ecologist, and an acclaimed writer.
She is a SUNY distinguished
teaching professor
at the SUNY College of
Environmental Science and Forestry
in Syracuse, New York.
She was also founding
director at the college
of the Center for Native
Peoples and the Environment,
the mission of which is to create programs
which draw on the wisdom
of both Indigenous and
scientific knowledge
for the shared goal of sustainability.
Professor Kimmerer's research
includes reproductive ecology, dispersal,
and community ecology of mosses
in Northeastern North America,
and the role, more recently,
the role of traditional
ecological knowledge
in ecological restoration.
In collaboration with tribal partners,
she and her students have
an active research program
in the ecology and restoration of plants
of cultural significance to Native people.
Professor Kimmerer is a member
of the Potawatomi Nation,
and she is the cofounder
and past president
of the Traditional
Ecological Knowledge Section
of the Ecological Society of America.
Professor Kimmerer is the author
of numerous scientific papers
on ecology of moss, restoration ecology,
and on contributions to
traditional ecology knowledge
to understanding our natural world.
She is also the author
of a number of acclaimed books,
including "Gathering Moss,"
which is an intimate account
of the biology and lives of mosses.
"Gathering Moss" was awarded
the prestigious John Burroughs Medal
for nature writing in 2005.
Her book "Braiding Sweetgrass:
"Indigenous Wisdom,
"Scientific Knowledge, and
the Teaching of Plants"
was also awarded
the Sigurd Olson Nature
Writing Award in 2013.
Throughout her writing,
Robin Kimmerer uses her
elegant and visionary voice
to tell intimate stories
about small, forgotten,
or overlooked communities,
from the tiny assemblages
of mosses in the forest
to the original Indigenous
nations of this continent.
Join me in welcoming Robin Wall Kimmerer.
(audience applauding)
Before we get started, I
wanna also let you know
that there'll be a
reception after the talk
directly down the hallway
at the end of the hallway,
so please stay around
and join us for that
continued conversation.
- Thank you so much.
Thank you all for being here,
for taking the time to come
together and share ideas.
Thanks to the Franke Center
for this wonderful invitation,
and having invited a plant ecologist
to come and speak with you,
you might be thinking we're
gonna see some data today.
Yeah, nope.
I love a good P value as
much as the next scientist,
but the kind of values we're
gonna be talking about today
lie at the intersection
of nature and culture.
We're really gonna be
looking at human values,
and instead of graphs and tables,
we're really gonna use
what my friend John Tallmadge has called
the most sophisticated
communication technology
ever devised,
and my students always
say, "You mean Google?"
And no, I say, "I mean the story,"
so we're gonna talk stories today,
but first, I wanna greet
you in my language.
I don't speak much of our language,
but our teachers and our Elders tell us
that because our language
is an endangered species,
we really need to breathe
life into it whenever we can
and use it,
so in the Potawatomi
language, I greet you.
I say (speaking in Potawatomi).
(audience speaking in Potawatomi)
(Robin speaking in Potawatomi)
I've told you that I
am a Potawatomi woman,
that my name is (speaking in Potawatomi),
the Light Shining through Sky Woman.
I'm a member of the Bear
Clan and also of the Eagles,
and I'm very grateful to be here with you,
and gratitude is our first responsibility,
and so let's just take a
moment to begin with gratitude,
to remember that this morning,
when we woke up, we put
our feet on Mother Earth,
and everything that we
needed was provided for us,
that we had water to drink.
We had beautiful clouds
moving across the sky
with that beautiful air.
We had food.
We had the companionship
of geese in the sky
and the companionship of
the bare-branched maples
and the companionship of each other,
so many gifts that come to us,
and our first responsibility,
then, is gratitude,
and I also want to give
a special gratitude
to the original peoples of this place,
the Pequot peoples, on
whose ancestral territory
we are sitting at this very moment.
To introduce today's talk
about the teachings of plants,
I want to introduce you to
one of my great teachers,
this plant called (speaks
in Potawatomi), sweetgrass.
Sweetgrass, in our language,
that word, (speaks in Potawatomi),
actually means something
about the beautiful
fragrance of that plant.
Has a lovely sort of vanilla odor to it.
It means the opened wet
meadows where it grows,
and it also means a call to
ceremony and a call to prayer
because this is a sacred plant for us.
This is a medicine plant.
It simultaneously heals the earth
because it's an early
successional rhizomatous perennial
that binds up disturbed soil,
but it is also a healer of spirit as well,
so this is an important medicine plant,
and while we call it
(speaks in Potawatomi),
you may know it as sweetgrass,
Linnaeus called it Hierochloe odorata,
and in botanical Latin,
that means the sacred,
fragrant, holy grass,
so I think Linnaeus knew
this plant very well.
We'll get back to Linnaeus
in just a little bit.
When you see a (speaks
in Potawatomi) like this,
you almost always see sweetgrass braided.
Anybody know why that is?
- [Audience Member] To make it stronger.
- It is certainly stronger.
The reason that we braid sweetgrass
is that sweetgrass is part
of our creation stories,
and that sweetgrass is understood
as one of the first plants
that grows on earth,
and we think of it as
the hair of Mother Earth,
and so now you know why we braid it.
Think about the last time
you braided someone's hair
or someone braided your hair,
and the gentle smiles that
I just saw emerge here
tell us why we braid sweetgrass
because it's a form of
relationship, isn't it, braiding?
We braid Mother Earth's hair
in the form of sweetgrass
as a sign of our tender care for her,
and so this important plant
comes to us as a braid,
and we'll have more to say
about that in a little bit.
This notion of braiding
sweetgrass, those three strands,
I also use as the dominant metaphor
in the book "Braiding Sweetgrass,"
thinking about each one of those strands,
of those three strands, one
as scientific knowledge,
one of them as Indigenous
traditional knowledge,
and the third, the knowledge
of the plants themselves
because both traditional
knowledge and scientific knowledge
are constructed knowledge by humans,
but we also have to acknowledge
the inherent wisdom and
knowledge that are in the plants,
and so that too is
represented in this braid,
all these ways of knowing,
but I have to tell you
that the relationship,
for me, as a Native scientist,
of those three ways of knowing
has not always been an easy
one, as you might imagine,
and let me just tell you
a little story about that.
Here you see, of course,
beautiful goldenrod and asters,
that purple and yellow.
They're so stunning together in the fall,
and I always loved this
combination of plants,
and I was born a botanist.
I can't remember a time
when I wasn't attracted to
and engaged with plants,
and this particular pair
has always been my favorite,
so when it came time to go to college,
I knew I had to study botany,
and when I went to school,
on my very first day,
my freshmen advisor said to me,
"So Miss Wall, why do you
want to be a botanist?"
And I said, "I want to know
"why goldenrod and New England asters
"look beautiful together."
(audience member chuckles)
That's just what he did. (laughs)
I wanted to know about relationship.
I wanted to know about harmony and beauty
because these plants do
look so stunning together,
and they often grow intermixed,
so they're aesthetically so gorgeous,
and I thought
there must be ecological
meaning to that as well,
but he said, (clears throat)
"My dear, that is not science,"
and so, as a person very much interested
in traditional Indigenous ways of knowing,
I said, "Well, I also want to
know why plants make medicine
"and why you can bend willows for baskets
"and not other plants,"
and he said, "Also not science."
He said, "If you want
to know those things,
"you shouldn't be in science,"
and so this was my first encounter
with the scientific worldview,
coming from an Indigenous worldview
of growing up on the land in my community,
and that's why I look so happy (laughs)
(audience laughing)
in my freshman photo.
I was stunned, quite honestly,
because I thought a question of beauty
was a darn good question,
but I was told it wasn't,
that it didn't matter,
and that if I was interested in beauty,
I should have gone to art school,
and I had no vocabulary for resistance.
I didn't know what to do about this.
I thought that I must've made a mistake
about what was important to me
and interesting about plants,
and so he signed me up for
my general botany classes,
and I went right in to take them,
but now, thinking back on that day
and my gleeful look on my first
day getting to study botany,
which was my dream come true,
was that it was really
a very powerful echo
of my grandfather's first day at school,
and my grandfather's first day of school
was when he was nine years old,
when he was taken from our
reservation in Oklahoma
and put on a train and sent
to the Carlisle Indian School.
His first day of school, kinda like mine,
where we were told, "What
you think doesn't matter.
"Your way of knowing, there's
no room for that here,"
but they didn't cut my hair,
and I could still speak
my own language, kind of,
because my language of
nature was nature as subject.
I understood the plants and the animals,
the insects, the birds around me
as beings, as persons,
and that the land, which I was
being told was the ecosystem,
I understood as a community,
a community of sovereign beings,
and with that worldview,
I have to tell you
that studying botany
was really challenging
because the organisms
that I had thought of
as persons, in a sense,
were now reduced to objects,
and, in fact, this was the model
that we were given of ecology,
that this is what an ecosystem was.
The ecosystem as machine,
not as community.
I thought I had wandered
into an engineering class by mistake,
nature as object,
because, again, within the
Indigenous way of thinking,
I was raised to understand
that every person has these four ways,
depicted in our medicine wheel,
of understanding the world:
mind, body, emotion, and spirit,
and we're always told
that unless you understand
with all of these four
gifts of human beings,
you don't really understand it,
but in going to the scientific worldview,
I went to a worldview that
just privileges the intellect
and that which can be observed
and measured by science,
but that very deliberately
sets aside spirit and emotion,
those other gifts that we have.
I had walked out of a worldview
in which land is understood
as a web of relationship
that brings all those things together.
What we didn't really understand,
I think, at that point was,
you mentioned pluralism,
that you have a speaker
coming to talk about pluralism in science,
that just as we know that the
driver of biological evolution
is genetic diversity,
that if we think about cultural evolution
toward sustainability,
toward right relationship with the earth,
that that requires intellectual diversity.
It requires all kinds of ways
of understanding our relationships,
and that is really the
work that we're doing
at the Center for Native
Peoples and the Environment
is to bring together
the wisdom and practices
of traditional Indigenous
environmental philosophy,
paired with the tools of Western science
to solve our most pressing
environmental problems,
and we like to think of it
not so much as a monoculture.
I don't know about you,
but what I experienced as
a brand-new college student
was an intellectual monoculture,
that the way to understand nature
was through the scientific lens only,
but what we're thinking about doing,
and we're trying to
practice in our center,
is to create a knowledge garden
inspired by the Three Sisters polyculture
grown by Native peoples
all over the continent,
where you know that
corn, beans, and squash
are not grown in isolation,
but they're grown together, right?
And it reduces competition between them.
They partner.
They support one another,
but the beans don't
become the squash, right?
There's not a privileging of
one over the other, a blending.
We have sovereign ways of
knowing that support each other,
and so the garden,
the knowledge garden that
we are trying to create
is this one, where we have a symbiosis
between traditional ecological knowledge
and Western science,
and then ourselves, as teachers,
as educators, as thinkers
to help create that symbiosis.
This is what we are trying to do,
so if we go back here to this
notion of nature as object
versus nature as subject,
this question of the nature
of nature, if you will,
is certainly not a new one,
and what I wanna talk
to you about today is
the notion of object
versus subject in plants
and thinking about plants as persons
and what we gain in that dialogue.
Two books that I wanna recommend to you,
if this is of any interest to you at all,
these wonderful books,
"The Philosopher's Plant"
and "Plants as Persons,"
are really great treatises
that have informed a lot of my thinking,
and we will begin, as we
do in the Western canon,
with the classics, right?
The Greek philosophers
who thought about the
nature of other beings
and whether or not
plants were living beings
was an active area of discussion,
and many of the early philosophers,
Plato and Theophrastus,
who was sort of the father of botany,
concluded that while plants
were very, very different from animals,
they were definitely living things.
They were not as close to rocks
as many of their
contemporaries had thought,
and they actually said
that plants have souls.
They have virtuous souls,
which are associated with their beauty,
with their generosity,
and with their provisioning
for everybody else,
but Aristotle suggested otherwise.
I love this quote:
"Some have said that
plants have intelligence
"and can acquire knowledge.
"Let us dismiss these theories as trivial
"and abide by sound reasoning."
He thought that if plants had any notion
of soul or being,
this is what he called a vegetal soul,
and a vegetal soul simply meant
that they had enough going on to grow,
to grow and to reproduce, but that's it,
and, of course, you think
in the scala naturae,
on the great chain of being,
where do plants occur?
Way down at the bottom
of this hierarchical ranked system, right?
In which the angels are on the
top, humans just below them,
and plants just above the rocks,
and this notion of plants as primitive,
the hierarchical ranking of beings
certainly underpins much of
our botanical sciences today,
as we'll see in just a second,
so this Western worldview,
placement of plants
as low man on the totem pole, right?
That they are at the bottom
of biological hierarchies,
primitive, lacking in most capacities.
While I would say that that idea
of low man on the totem pole
needs some critique in
a number of regards,
particularly what does it mean
to be low man on the totem pole?
A common misperception by Westerners
looking at this marvelous art
of the Pacific Northwest coast
is that the one who is on top
of the totem pole
is the most powerful and the most honored.
That's pretty consistent
with our biological hierarchies, right?
Where we are at the really
top, but that's not true.
In this art form,
the most influential, the
one on which everyone relies,
is at the bottom of the totem pole,
perhaps right where plants are,
the most influential and important
taking their place right there.
Like the plants at the
base of the food chain,
they hold everything else up,
and in contrast
to this hierarchical way
of thinking about plants
with plants at the bottom
and humans at the top,
in the Indigenous worldview,
from the dreamtime of
Aboriginal Australians
to my own Potawatomi people,
the plants are viewed as
persons, as full-fledged persons,
with their own gifts,
their own intelligences,
their own intentions, their
own ways of being in the world,
and when I say that plants
are understood as persons,
I don't mean this kind of
person, a fictional person,
like the familiar Ents of Fangorn Forest,
and I certainly don't mean these persons.
Isn't it interesting?
All you have to do is put a face on things
and suddenly they become beings.
Anthropomorphism at its very
best: a smile on a carrot.
The kind of personhood that I mean,
as a reflection of
Indigenous ways of knowing,
is not anthropomorphic.
It is not assigning human characters
to plants at all.
In fact, what it does
is to celebrate the fact
that plants are very different,
very different ways of
being than humankind,
but they, too, are persons.
They, too, are autonomous beings
with their own experiences,
their own perceptions,
and indeed, their own agency in the world.
A person can have intelligence,
sensation, self-recognition.
A person bears their own capacities,
and most importantly to
our discussion today,
a person is capable of
entering into relationship,
particularly into
reciprocal relationships.
Not only in Potawatomi culture
and those of many of my relative nations
are plants viewed as persons,
but they are viewed as teachers,
as among our highest,
most revered of teachers,
and why should this be?
In the Western world, these organisms,
which are viewed as practically
nothing, close to the rocks,
are revered as teachers
among Indigenous peoples.
Part of it is the understanding
that they have been part,
they have been here on earth
far longer than any other beings,
but there's really the recognition
that what other beings on earth
can take light and air
and water, and make food,
and then give it away?
Great healthcare plan or food plan.
They make medicine too.
That's their healthcare plan.
They make medicines and
give them away for free.
Plants are understood as generous agents,
generative agents as well,
creative beings that teach
us how to be in the world,
teach us how to,
what it is to be a
right being in the world
because you're constantly
engaged in give and take,
and so you see that if you
come with that worldview
into the botany lab,
where you're just simply dissecting plants
and thinking of them as objects,
that's kind of an uphill slog,
so I'm so excited by the new
fields of plant neurobiology
that are doing some really amazing work
to demonstrate, in fact,
that plants do have
their own agency, right?
That plants can make choices,
that plants can hear
and respond to sounds,
that plants have memory,
that plants can plan ahead.
All of these attributes of
personhood, of beingness,
that we're now finding in the
plant biology laboratories
are, in a sense, an echo
of what our traditional
teachers always told us,
and there's certainly no question
that plants provide generously,
as their original instructions were to do,
for all of us, for human beings,
given all the medicines that they make us,
the other resources that they make us,
and I wanna pause for a
moment on that term resources
because whether it be food or
timber or ecosystem services,
all of these things are things
that my natural resource
conservation biology colleagues
refer to as either ecosystem
services or natural resources,
and that language has certain
consequences, doesn't it?
When we think about the
beingness of plants,
natural resources,
that which is not valuable
until it is transmuted into
something that humans need.
The language in our Potawatomi language,
of which I am just a beginning student,
the name that we would give
to natural resources is gifts,
that all of these are gifts,
and gifts, therefore, open us
to a relationship, don't they?
When somebody gives us a gift,
what do we do with that gift?
What do we do in response to that gift?
We what?
(audience member speaks faintly)
We say, "Thank you."
We enter into gratitude,
and as I said, gratitude
is our first responsibility
because gratitude acknowledges
the gifts of the world,
things that we have never,
that we have not bought and paid for,
things that we don't necessarily deserve,
but they are given to us,
and when somebody gives you a gift,
yes, you say, "Thank you,"
and then what?
What's the next step?
- [Audience Member] Give back.
- You give back, right?
Gratitude and gift open
the door to reciprocity,
and this is another reason
that the plants are
understood as our teachers
because they teach us,
from the seed to the fruit
and back to the seed,
they teach us about reciprocity
and what is our role?
So if we think about
plants as our teachers,
the question then becomes
how can we be better students?
What is it that they are teaching us?
And how can we be better students?
And I wanna tell you
another story about that
related to notions of sustainability.
My friend Carol Crowe, who
is an Algonquin biologist,
went to her band council,
which is the tribal government,
to ask for a grant to go to a
conference on sustainability,
and so she went before
her Elders and was asking,
and they said, "Well,
what's sustainability?"
And she kind of laughed,
thinking, "Well, that's the way our people
"have been living so well in
this place for millennia,"
but she used these definitions
that are familiar to all of you, right?
Lots and lots of different definitions
of this slippery word, sustainability,
but in these excerpts that
I've highlighted here,
one of the things that is
certainly present in all of these,
ensure the attainment and
continued satisfaction
of human needs.
Continue to provide.
Do not diminish the
potential to meet the needs,
so she told her Elders all that,
and they were very quiet,
and she thought they
were gonna turn her down,
and they said, "No, we want you to go.
"It's very important that
you go to that meeting,
"but we want you to go
and tell them something.
"Carry a message
"and tell them that their
idea of sustainability
"is really a way to just keep on taking."
Just keep on taking.
They said to her, "You go,
"and tell them that it's not
our right to keep taking."
When our feet hit the
ground in the morning,
we should be thinking what
it is that we have to give.
Just as the plants
are constantly giving
to us in reciprocity,
what is it that we have to give back
in return for this shower of gifts
that comes to us every day?
And sustainability, as a
powerful cultural goal,
is completely reframed
by this notion, isn't it?
Of not about taking, but about giving,
and this is one of the instances
in which the lens of Indigenous knowledge
and environmental philosophy
can reshape the way that
we think and contribute
to that cultural evolution
we spoke of at the outset
because traditional ecological knowledge
is full of stories and
practices and philosophies
about ways in which human people
have a beneficial
relationship with the earth.
When I teach general ecology,
I ask my students, "How
well versed are you
"in negative relationships
between people and the earth?"
And every hand goes up.
They know all about that,
but then, when I ask them the opposite,
"What about positive relationships
"between people and the earth?"
there are very few hands,
and so how is it
that we're trying to
train the next generation
of environmental stewards
when we cannot even imagine
what positive, mutualistic,
reciprocal relationships
might look like with the earth,
and this lens, this framework
from the Indigenous worldview,
is a powerful tool for moving there.
In fact, what Carol's Elders,
the Cree Elders were essentially saying
is that we should be thinking
not what more can we take from the earth?
But what does the earth ask of us?
What is our role as human people
in response to these gifts?
How do we reciprocate
the many gifts of plants
from every breath of oxygen that we take,
to food, to medicine, to
beauty, to companionship,
to them being our teachers?
And one of the most powerful ways
in a world that is full of
Monarch butterflies and goldenrod
and asters and redwoods and
salamanders and bluejays,
a world which is full of
all of these other beings,
shouldn't we at least be paying attention?
And we're not.
Our whole society suffers greatly
from what has been called plant blindness,
of not really even being
aware of the gifts of plants,
and one of the ways that we
talk about paying attention
is by knowing names,
and yeah, I'm a botanist,
so, of course, you think, "Well, yep,
"she's gonna go on about
plant taxonomy now."
Well, yeah, a little, (chuckles)
but more than that,
when you come to know the
name of your neighbor,
doesn't that bring you into relationship?
It opens the potential for reciprocity.
When you don't even bother
to learn the name of somebody around you,
that's a sign of disrespect,
and so by not knowing the name
of the one who makes the
aspirin for you every day
or the one who makes the syrup
that you pour on your
pancakes on Sunday morning,
if you don't even know their names,
it's an act of disrespect,
and so there's the
notion of learning names
by paying attention.
This little plant
grows in everybody's
backyard here, I'm sure,
or along your sidewalk.
Does anybody know this plant?
- [Audience Member] Heal-all.
(audience member speaks indistinctly)
- Yes. Wonderful.
Say that again. I'm in a
botanically literate audience.
Heal-all. That would be a good
name to know, wouldn't it?
If you just needed to
start with one plant name,
heal-all would probably be a good one.
Remarkable plant.
I wish I had time to talk
all about its chemistry,
but it does.
It really heals a lot.
- What was that (indistinct)?
What was the last one?
- The plants?
- [Audience Member] Yes.
- This is a camas
meadow, Camassia quamash,
a plant, again, all of
these plants are in here
because they are stories of reciprocity.
This is a plant that people
need to tend by burning
in order to bring the camas to fruit.
Okay, paying attention,
knowing names,
a number of educators, of course,
have pointed out that we
are natural taxonomists.
We categorize, we learn names like crazy,
and our kids, and let's
face it, ourselves,
we're pretty good at this, aren't we?
Recognizing corporate logos.
Who is it that really
sustains us in the world?
Where are we giving our attention?
Our natural means of, or natural tendency
to pay attention to that
which supports our life
has, in a sense, been
hijacked by advertisers.
It is, to me, terrifying
that kids can recognize
100 corporate logos
and recognize fewer than 10 plants.
The average American knows
fewer than 10 plants,
and you know what tops the list?
Christmas tree and grass,
so those don't hardly even count, right?
So we have a problem with plant blindness.
How can we understand and
relate to the world as gift
if we don't even know the gift-givers,
if we don't even know their names
or anything about what
it is that they offer us
every single day?
How can we be better students
of plants? Pay attention.
Know about their gifts.
Share that knowledge
with those around you,
and speaking of plant names,
I said I'd get back to Linnaeus, right?
Hierochloe odorata that he
gave the name to sweetgrass.
What you see here are two
great botanists and namers.
We all know that Linnaeus
is the great namer,
and when we all took Bio 101,
we were told that he was, in fact,
the father of naming and taxonomy
because before 1770, no one
had names for plants? (laughs)
Well, on the other side,
you see Nanabush,
Nanabozho in our culture.
You know, when Nanabozho came to the earth
as the first man, Anishinaabe man,
he was given a job by the creator,
and his job was to give names,
but how was he different from Linnaeus?
Linnaeus bestowed names in
a foreign language, right?
In a standardized scientific nomenclature,
he bestowed names,
and naming, as we know,
is a powerful act of control,
as well as attention.
How did Nanabush do it?
Nanabush didn't give names.
His job was to wander the world
getting to know all the
plants and animals so well
that they would reveal
to him their real names,
and here we see, again,
this subject versus object.
Who has the right to give a name?
If it's an object, you can
call it anything you want.
If it's a subject, you wouldn't presume.
You would wait to know and
have the true name be revealed,
so we have, again, this different lenses
for looking at the beingness of nature
as object and subject,
and this brings me to...
How am I doing on...
There we go. I can see the clock now.
A peculiarity of language.
We talked about natural
resources versus gift
as an interesting linguistic idea,
but I'd like you to think
for just a little bit
about how we refer to the living world
in the English language.
All these beings, all these gifts,
and if I was to say something
about (speaks in Potawatomi), the bear,
I would have to say it's
scratching the tree, right?
It.
I would have to refer to
all of these beings as it
because in English, we have
a very peculiar grammar
that we don't often think about,
but in English, you're either
a human or you're an it.
If your grandma was standing there
making soup at the stove,
and someone said, "Oh, look,
it's wearing an apron."
That's not right.
It's not only rude,
but we just really
disrespected her, right?
We took her humanity, her
personhood away from her.
She who was about to provide for us,
but in English, how do we speak
of all of those bearers of
gifts in the natural world
who provide for us?
We only say it of them, right?
And even in our language, in
our beautiful English language,
this notion of object and
the lack of personhood,
lack of beingness is present,
and I think that we can think about this
in the consequences for our worldview
and the way that we relate to the land.
This imposition of the notion of it
is really a tool of
linguistic imperialism.
It is a tool of colonization,
which we feel acutely today
in our relationships
with the living world,
and, you know, in the Potawatomi language
it's impossible to say
it of the living world.
You can't do it.
We speak of that bluejay
and of that strawberry
with the same grammar that
we use for our family members
because they are our family members,
and so encoded in this
little piece of grammar
is a worldview, isn't it?
Of objectified nature,
and if nature is an object,
if it's not made up of beings and persons,
then we have a certain kind
of permission, if you will,
to exploit it
because when we objectify people,
when we objectify nature,
we're very good at this,
it creates a circle of moral exclusion.
It says you're other,
and generally speaking,
where are natural beings
on that hierarchy?
Those others are lower-than,
lesser-than beings,
and so this objectification of nature,
which is captured in our
worldview and in our language,
I think is emblematic of our relationship,
and so what I'd like to do
is to invite you into a little experiment,
to think about how Indigenous
languages the world over
have this concept of
animacy in the language,
that you cannot say it
about a living being.
It's just not possible.
We speak a grammar of animacy,
and could we, in some
way, animate English?
Could we step away from
objectification of the living world
by being very conscious
about the way that we speak?
And so the proposal
is a modest proposal.
The pronouns of the revolution.
Reclaim the grammar of animacy.
Change, begin to change our thinking
and the way that we behave
in the living world through grammar,
and I thought for a long time of
how in the world could you do this?
So I asked one of my Elders,
my language teachers,
"Is there a word in Potawatomi
"for a living being of the earth?"
so that they don't, not to
say that they are humans.
It's not anthropomorphism,
but you're a being.
Is there a word?
And there is; it's bmaadiziaki,
and it simply means a living
being of the good earth,
actually means a good
being of the living earth.
That's right, and so
there is a word for it.
There is a concept for it, which
is built into our language,
and when we look at that
beautiful word, bmaadiziaki,
in a culture where we can,
where we rarely tolerate
speaking a language other than English,
I don't think that incorporation
of bmaadiziaki into our language
is really going to work,
but what about ki?
Ki, that last phoneme
on the beautiful word aki,
which means the earth,
which sounds a bit like he and she.
Could we refer to living
beings, not as its,
with a disrespectful objectification
as if they were just a
paperclip or a pencil.
We use it for them, not
for sacred living beings
who are our teachers and our providers.
Could we say of that
maple tree in the spring,
"Ki is giving us sap this year?
"Ki's branches are waving in the wind."
Could we refine our language
and pause for a moment to think:
are these living beings
or are they objects?
And I went back and forth with my Elders
talking about this word,
and we had some concerns
about cultural appropriation
associated with this,
with inspiring a new grammar of animacy,
and we had lots of very
interesting discussions about that,
so we were really grateful
that English already has a word
that works for the plural of ki
because in Potawatomi,
to make a word plural,
you add an N.
We already have that word.
We already have that word
so that when the geese
fly back in the spring,
we can say, "Kin are filling the skies.
"Welcome back,"
so that every time we
speak of the living world,
we speak of relationship,
of respectful relationship
with place and with beings.
How do we reciprocate
the gifts of the plants?
This notion of personhood
is far more than a notion of a pronoun.
What we're really talking about
is extension of thinking about personhood
to living beings, right?
And this has ramifications
in the political,
legal worlds,
as well as the ecological worlds
because what you're looking at here
is the sacred river of the Maori people.
This is the Whanganui River
that four years ago
was declared a legal person
out of the Maori concepts
of animacy of all beings.
That river is understood
and has legal personhood,
so decisions about that
river need to be made
for the wellbeing of that river,
so these ideas of personhood
are not kind of arcane constructs;
they have real meaning in the world.
It's really interesting, isn't it?
That in this country,
the only things that can be
recognized as legal persons,
aside from ourselves,
are corporations, right?
But the rest of the,
particularly in the Indigenous-led world
has other ideas about that
because, as you know, in Ecuador,
the constitution of Ecuador
enshrines the personhood of nature,
assigning rights to Pachamama,
rights that Mother Nature has
her own inherent rights.
Implementation of this
is far more difficult
than conceptualization of it,
but here we have it,
and it's true in Bolivia as well,
and Bolivia was the leader of a coalition
to bring before the United Nations
the Universal Declaration of
the Rights of Mother Earth,
which is also this notion of personhood,
of subjecthood for Mother Nature,
for Pachamama, for Gaia,
for all the different languages
in which we think of her,
and so these ideas from
Indigenous ways of thinking,
of plants as persons, as
teachers, as esteemed beings,
is finding its way into international law.
The Paris climate talks
was one of the first
courts for crimes against nature
in addition, parallel to
crimes against humanity,
so if we consider plants to be persons,
that has implications
for how we relate to plants
as consumers, does it not?
If plants are persons,
in the Western world,
where we say that plants are not persons
or even so much, in many cases, beings,
certainly not legal persons,
we refer to them all as it,
that permission to exploit
means that we don't really have to worry
about the ethical consequences of it
'cause it's just a thing,
and they are outside our circle
of moral or ecological compassion.
In Indigenous ways of thinking,
remember, if we're
thinking about the plants
as beings, as teachers, as our relatives,
and we're gonna eat them?
This sets up certain
ethical tensions, for sure,
but it's really important
that they're there
because as (indistinct), as human beings,
we can't photosynthesize.
We have to eat plants.
We can't just call them it
and have no ethics associated with it.
We recognize them as
persons and our relatives,
so we have to have very special ethics
associated with honoring
the lives that they give us,
and this is encoded in
a series of practices
which are understood as
the Honorable Harvest,
so when we recognize the plants
as gift-givers, as beings, as teachers,
rules come up
for essentially consuming
your beloved family,
and these rules were taught
to me as a berry picker,
as a medicine gatherer,
and they may seem, at first,
like kind of quaint prescriptions
for how it is that we go berry picking,
but I think you'll see
that they are potentially very strong ways
to reconceptualize
and enact our relationship with the earth.
When I go to pick berries,
maybe this is same for you,
we say that we never take the first one.
We come upon the first ones,
and we greet them, and
say "Thank you" to them,
and we pass them by.
This self-restraint
is an inherent conservation
ethic, isn't it?
Because if you don't take the first one,
you're not going to take the last one,
and when we come to the
one that we can take,
in some cultures, it's the third one,
some cultures, it's the seventh one,
we ask permission.
We actually speak to that
plant, introduce ourselves,
and ask that plant if
it has enough to share.
Would you allow me
to bring some medicine
home for my daughter?
Some berries home for that pie?
We ask permission,
and I understand that if you
came upon somebody in the woods
who was talking to a
patch of strawberries,
you might think that they
were a little over the edge,
but in our culture,
it's just good manners.
It's good manners.
Would you go into your grandmother's house
and start rifling through
her cupboards for cookies?
Yeah, you laughed. Yeah.
Only once. (laughs) You'd
only do that once, right?
And in a sense,
that's how we treat our
beloved grandmother the earth.
We just go take whatever we want,
but the Honorable Harvest
says, "No, you don't.
"You ask permission."
You ask permission,
and then your grandma
will probably give you
all the cookies that you
want on her best china plate,
and if you ask permission,
you have to listen for the answer,
and understanding plants
as beings, as persons,
there are many ways to answer that.
As a scientist, I listen for that answer
and look at the population density
and look at the vigor of the plants.
Do they have enough to
share? So on and so forth.
There are biological, empirical ways
to listen for that answer,
but there are also intuitive
ways to listen for that answer,
and if the answer is no, you go home.
You go home with an empty basket
because they don't belong to you.
If we take without permission,
what is that called?
Stealing.
Right, so we take with honor.
We don't take unless we have permission.
Take only what you need, of
course. We all know that.
Much harder to practice.
Minimize harm in the way
that you're taking it.
The lesson that was given
to me is never use a shovel
if a digging stick will do.
Use appropriate technology.
Minimize the harm
that comes from your taking
from the natural world.
Use everything that you take
because you are taking a life.
You are taking a life
or a life is being given to you
in this gift from the plants.
This applies to animals as well,
and we don't disrespect that.
Practice gratitude. Be grateful.
Be grateful for everything
that is given to you,
and gratitude, again,
may seem like sort of a hollow
good manners or politeness,
but gratitude is really powerful
because when you practice gratitude,
it helps you remember
that you have everything
that you need already.
It makes you feel abundant,
and gratitude, practicing gratitude
brings you into relationship
with all that is,
with those beings.
You can't feel separated
when you're grateful,
and you know what?
I've recently read
some really interesting
studies about consumption,
and we know that it is consumption
that has us hanging on the
brink of climate chaos.
It is consumption that has led
us into the sixth extinction,
and you know,
one of the correlates to
restraint on consumption
is gratitude.
People who practice
gratitude consume less,
so this ethic has real
concrete repercussions.
Share everything that you've taken.
The plants have shared with you,
and so we, then, have to
share what we've taken.
You take those strawberries
and give them to somebody else
as well as to your family,
and always reciprocate the gift.
In return for those
berries, for that root,
you need to give something back,
and there's a lot of teachings
about what that something could be.
It could be, in the case of berries,
you're gonna weed around them
and reduce the competition for them.
It could be you're
gonna pick the bugs off.
It could be you're gonna take the seeds
and carry them to a new
place and plant them.
Really practical things
that your gift of attention and respect
pay off for that plant
so that you flourish and the
plant flourishes as well.
Oftentimes, the gifts are
also spiritual in nature,
giving a prayer, giving
words, giving a song,
giving, in my culture,
tobacco, sacred plant,
giving back to that plant,
so reciprocating the gift
is a very important law of taking,
and I'm almost out of time,
so I think what I wanna do
is to close with this notion
of reciprocity and the gift.
In our culture, we are told
that gifts and responsibilities
are two sides of the same coin,
so that when we think about a bird
singing in the morning,
we'd say, "Well, that bird was given
"this beautiful gift of song,"
and then the whole world
receives it as a gift
because it's so beautiful
and makes you feel so good in the morning,
but in return for that gift
that the bird was given,
it has a responsibility
to sing up the sun,
so the gift comes with
a responsibility, right?
So that's what we mean.
The stars were given
this gift of twinkling
and the responsibility
to show us our directions at night.
Everything comes in this duality
of gift and responsibility,
and when we think about
the difficulties that face us
in this particular time,
we could ask ourselves with heavy heart,
"What's my responsibility?"
And sometimes, that's harder to answer,
but what if you asked
yourself, "What is my gift?"
What is my gift?
And then that becomes,
giving your gift becomes
the responsibility,
and is your gift as a teacher?
As a scientist? As an artist?
As a writer? As a parent?
As a gardener? As an engineer?
What is your gift?
And the notion of this coupling
of gifts and responsibilities
is that in return for the gifts
that we are given by the earth,
that each of us is called upon
to give our gift in return,
so that collectively we might do
what Onondaga Clan
Mother Audrey Shenandoah
beseeched us to do,
and that is to seek justice,
not only for ourselves, but
justice for all creation.
(speaks in Potawatomi),
thank you very much.
(audience applauding)
Thank you.
- [Man] You have an
opportunity for some questions-
- Sure.
(man speaks indistinctly)
You bet. You bet.
Any questions?
Any questions or comments?
(man speaks indistinctly)
Oh, here comes one.
- [Audience Member] Thank you, Robin.
It was a beautiful talk. John Grimm.
I recall in an article by Winona LaDuke
that she opened it
by talking about (speaks
in foreign language),
and she translated it or gave it
as long life, happiness,
living into old age,
and I caught,
among your names of the
plant, (speaks tentatively)-
- Bmaadiziaki,
uh-huh, yeah.
- So I was looking
for the relationship between the Ojibwe
rendition of a value in life,
a primary, central value in life,
and here this value is then
embedded in plants, huh?
- Yes, and to clarify,
Ojibwe and Potawatomi
are very close languages,
member of the same language family,
and the notion of (speaks in Potawatomi)
means a good and full life.
It has many nuances
of what does it mean to
have a good and full life,
but it literally means to walk
in a good way on the earth,
and so the notion of bmaadiziaki
that I've used here
is one who is living
that (speaks in Potawatomi), on the earth,
so yeah.
- [Audience Member] Plants
are (speaks faintly)
in that way also.
- Yes, yeah, yeah. Good question.
- [Amy] Thank you very much.
I can feel very moved.
I can feel very close to
so many of the concepts
that you were talking about today.
I feel that my culture is so far away from
(sobs) jeez,
so I'm wondering how do we take
the steps, little or small,
to begin to turn that around
as individuals in this society?
- Yeah, Amy, I-
- [Amy] Sorry.
- No, Amy, I honor your
emotion about that
because it is a grief.
It is a grief to know
that we have this world
of these beings who are sustaining us
and the way we treat
those who take care of us
in such a, well, such a way
is a source of grief,
and I really think about
Joanna Macy's wonderful work
of understanding that our
grief is a measure of our love,
and that, to me,
as we try to heal this great rift
of objectification of the living world,
I think the notion of paying attention
is really, really important,
and not relegating, paying
attention to living beings,
to nature over there,
that we have to go to
rainforests of Ecuador
to know nature,
that we have to go to the
Adirondacks to know nature,
that our regard for living
beings are in our garden
and in the cracks of our sidewalk.
Pay attention.
Pay attention, and I think
that all of these things
that could transform the way that we are
are our human gifts.
We don't have to invent this
because we're really good at gratitude.
We're really good at gift-giving,
and when we turn those to
living beings around us,
then we really have something.
We don't have to invent something new.
We have to extend our human,
the compassion that we feel sometimes
for some humans to the living world.
- [Amy] But then, maybe as a followup,
I can see us individually
committing to that and doing that.
Do you have any insights
as to how we create greater
change in our entire society
in the consumerism that we do embody
that we see all around us?
Our governance and things like that?
How do we,
do you have thoughts on how
that can become big enough
so that there is systemic change?
- Yeah, of course,
like probably every
one of us in this room,
we wrestle with exactly that question
of how do we scale this
to worldview change?
Because that is what we're doing.
We have to scale it,
and one of the things
that I have found important to talk about,
and the reason that I spend a
great deal of time and effort,
both writing and teaching and speaking
about Indigenous knowledge systems
is because I think we have
somehow gotten trapped
into the notion that the relationship,
the damaged relationship
that you're talking about,
the one that brings us grief
through our estrangement
from the living world,
we tend to think that that's our default,
that that's just the way it is,
that's just the way it is for humanity,
but what we have forgotten
is that it's really
just an eyeblink of time
that we have been in this
objectified worldview.
For most of human history,
we have lived with notions
of gratitude and reciprocity
and lived well and richly.
It is if we have been doing an experiment
since the Industrial Revolution
of what would it be like
if we treated the world as
if it was it instead of you?
Instead of ki? Instead of kin?
We've been doing an experiment to say,
"What if we treated the
world as if it was dead?"
And the experiments, or the data from,
the results from those
experiments are in, right?
And we don't like them,
and so I think it's really
important to know that
and to speak about that,
that there are other ways to be
that are coherent, long products
of cultural evolution in place,
and there are so many tools.
I mean, when we talk about
being there, being on the land,
paying attention, conversations,
stories, science,
all the gifts that every one
of you in this room possess
if deployed toward this notion,
I think can be very powerful.
It's not gonna happen from the top.
(audience chuckles)
- [Rayna] Hi. Thanks.
I'm Rayna. Thank you for your talk.
I was wondering.
I was very intrigued
by your thoughts on language and culture,
sort of what you alluded to just now,
and I'm from Greece,
so in Greek language, we do
have gender for everything.
We don't say it, pretty much for anything,
except for a few neutral things,
but I regret to say that doesn't make us
any more nicer to the earth
or thoughtful or anything.
What do you think it's gonna take,
other than changing the language,
in terms of getting people
to actually see that,
and what are the other
tools that we can use?
'Cause I feel like language
might be one small part of it,
but it will take a lot more.
- Absolutely. Absolutely.
People have brought me
so many examples of,
"Wait, we have animacy in our language,
"and yeah, we're not doing so well,"
so it certainly isn't,
and we're not talking
about deterministic here.
It is often correlated,
but it's certainly not deterministic.
One of my students actually
had an interesting insight
about this notion of the changed pronouns.
She said, "Do you remember
that we used to say,
"when the fire truck
would go by, we would say,
"'Well, the firemen are
going to put out the fire.'"
But do we say that anymore?
We say firefighters, don't we?
A cultural shift has occurred,
a little cultural shift in language,
and we pause, and we say, "firefighter"
because in that pause,
we're saying both men and women can be,
can put out blazes,
and just in that pause of
choosing to use a different word,
it reflects change and it propels change,
and so this notion
of pausing before saying
it about living beings
could have some of that same effect,
but it's about so much more than language.
What we really need is a change of hearts,
and this is why, for me, as a scientist,
I feel like I'm, well, I
don't think we need more data.
I don't think we need more information.
I don't think we need
to change technology.
We need to change our hearts,
but truthfully, I think
that we already have that,
that we have that innate sense
of wonder and love and
beauty for the natural world,
but we have to let it out.
We have to free it,
and there's all these things around us
that push us down so that we can't,
but we have to just choose it.
We have to choose it.
- [Audience Member] Maybe
a partial hopeful answer
about how we can.
Sorry.
Maybe a partial hopeful answer
about how we can start to
move the society a little bit.
I thought I was the only one.
I thought, in fact, that my recent
and incredibly increased
attention toward plants.
I used to, when my parents were alive,
be polite about their gardens,
but I wasn't paying attention.
After they died,
I got so mind-bogglingly
amazed at what plants do
that I thought I was being haunted,
but anyway,
then I realized, as I read around a bit,
this is a common pattern
that people, as they age,
frequently do get this way,
and I remembered that
the Voltaire "Candide"
at the end of that whole story,
what Candide and Cunegonde do is
tend their garden into old age,
so we have an avalanche
of aging people here.
I think it's time
to start to push paying
attention to plants
as a really fine thing
that can help heal the society,
and the sense of gratitude,
as I understand it,
is a huge key to happy aging.
- Well said, well said,
and time in the garden
is a perfect place to
understand plants as beings
and plants as gifts, and
our relationship to them.
Yeah, both the way
that you phrased your question
and your question itself
makes me think of a way to
pull together this question
that none of us have the answer to of
how do we change our world?
But again, I wanna come
back to this notion of
what we already know that
we don't have to invent,
and I've come to see my work,
both as a scientist, as
a writer, as a teacher,
and as a parent and a
grandparent, as a human being,
is to help people, again,
come to fall in love with the world,
and when we fall in love with
the world, all else follows,
and a garden is a great place to begin.
- [Audience Member] Hello. Thank you.
I am struck that
the way I heard your description
of the Honorable Harvest
works really well
for very low-impact
gathering and maybe hunting,
but anytime we're doing something else,
even the most ecologically
sensitive polyculture farming
or something like
selectively burning certain areas
to promote the growth of
particular species there,
that's us saying,
"We're choosing what lives there," right?
When we move around, when we live places,
we have these bubbles of
controlled ecologies around us,
and in that,
any of those,
and these comes in many different ways,
that's us selectively saying,
"We're going to destroy what's here
"and put something else there
"or allow something else to grow there,"
and unless you invoke
metaphysics, which I'm
not averse to doing;
I am a religious person,
the rest of the world would
be at least as better off,
if not much better off,
without our participation,
and so
I am coming to a place of nihilism
that this kind of
reciprocal relationship
is something that is ever
attainable at anywhere.
- Yeah, I hear your question,
and there's so much more wrapped up in it.
The only tiny little story,
slides that I didn't get to,
is we asked ourselves
exactly that question of
how can we take in such a way
that promotes life,
promotes regeneration, in a sense,
under the agency of the plants?
Can we have a true mutualism?
And let me just tell you
this tiny little story.
It is about sweetgrass.
We did some experimental
work with sweetgrass,
which is harvested by basket
makers and Native people,
and I'm trying to think of
how to abbreviate this story.
The plant was declining,
and so one of the questions
that the basket makers
came to us at the center
asking for some help
in understanding this,
and because the plant was declining,
what does Western conservation
biology tells us we must do
when that plant is becoming endangered?
We have to leave it alone, right?
Because nature and people are a bad mix.
We have to stay away from that.
We have to stop harvesting the sweetgrass
so that it can recover.
The basket makers, the
Indigenous basket makers,
told us something a little bit different.
They told us a lot of
different, a lot of information,
but one of the things that
we learned from them is
we evaluated the response
of sweetgrass to harvesting,
and so we had a plot
where we didn't take any,
and we know what would
happen there, right?
The sweetgrass would flourish
because we weren't messing with it,
and then we had other plots
where we harvested the sweetgrass
according to the Honorable Harvest,
and then we went and measured,
used all our plant ecology
tools to measure the success,
and do you know what happened?
The plots of plants that
had no human intervention,
that had no harvesters
there singing to them,
taking their, receiving their
gifts and reciprocating,
the control plots
that Western science said
should thrive declined.
The plots that were harvested
according to the Honorable
Harvest doubled in their vigor.
What we saw was that
practice of the Honorable
Harvest with sweetgrass
was a stimulus to the
growth of those plants
in taking and accepting the gift
and reciprocating with care,
the plants then regenerated,
so there are models out
there of true mutualism,
true reciprocity among beings,
and I don't want to
oversimplify this in any way
because there are plenty of plants
that wouldn't respond in that same way,
but I hold that up as an example of
when we shift our frame to say,
"Well, what are the ways
in which humans and plants
"could be mutually
beneficial to one another?"
we find them,
and working with Native communities,
really around the world,
listening to them talk about this concept,
there are so many examples
of plants that flourish
when people harvest them,
and don't diminish if you
use the Honorable Harvest.
A long answer, but a good question.
Yes.
- One last question.
- [Audience Member] Are
you heartened at all?
First of all, thank you.
That was a wonderful talk.
Are you heartened at all by trends
like the locavore food
movement and community gardens,
especially in poor,
underserved communities?
- Absolutely. Absolutely.
To me, that is one of the most important,
and as you say, heartening examples.
When the local food movement began,
I was a little skeptical about it.
It seemed like it was coming
from a place of great
privilege and so forth,
but what I'm seeing in
the local food movement
is that it is reawakening our relationship
to land, to soil, to water,
and it's cutting across all borders,
from urban gardens
to the Indigenous food
sovereignty movement
to anti-Monsanto kinds
of political movements,
so yeah, I think the food
movement is a huge indicator
and maybe even a tool of reshaping
our relationship to earth
'cause everybody eats.
- [Man] Thank you very much.
- Thanks.
(audience applauding)
Thank you.
(tranquil music)